you know it's like anything you debate
so i'm sitting there debating somebody
on the topic of guns
and there's no way i can win this debate
i'm like why is this person debating it
with me in such a strong way there's no
matter what i say this this woman's not
gonna and he eventually realized you
know uh her kid her husband they
believed in guns they let the gun out
the kid grabs it and shoots herself and
boom i mean that
no matter how the more you debate this
person
on the freedoms of gun and second
amendment the more she's hating you the
more she's like the more so there is no
winning that debate right so for me
there's not a black and white in this
when it comes down to talking because
everyone's got a little bit of a
different story and that's personal the
only thing you know is your life the
only thing i know is my life the only
thing we know is to get our and then
whatever books we get our hands on it's
kind of tough to get to the truth
uh uh on the other way around but if you
don't mind taking the argument that you
made i thought it was so profound i
wouldn't mind you unpacking a little bit
more where you said if there's all these
arguments if there's all these uh
uh uh two billion christians you got 1.1
muslims why is it that those 1.1 muslims
believe everybody else who doesn't
believe in their god is an atheist or
you know the argument you were making
would you mind going through that
argument on
why you think people man created god
rather than god created man
yeah sure uh i'll do that in a moment
but you brought up a good example of
guns guns
are another religious like
uh value that people hold it's in my
opinion because i've done a number of
gun debates i think we do need some gun
control even though i used to be against
gun control as a former libertarian now
classical liberal uh i i discovered that
people um
that gun belief in guns is a proxy for
something else for freedom for liberty
for the american way for for some deeper
value
so in that extent it doesn't matter how
many people are shot every year and
homicides accidental
uh childhood uh you know guns going off
and things like that it's irrelevant
there's no amount of people that could
die that's gonna
change the way they feel about guns
because it's not about the guns it's
about the second amendment it's about
constitution freedom liberty autonomy uh
self-defense and you know these kind of
deeper
features and and it's a lot of religious
truths work that way
and so it's whenever you're talking to
somebody about politics or religion it's
always good to figure out
what's the deeper moral value behind the
specific thing they're talking about
immigration or abortion or whatever
because they're you're if they're if
they're pretty stubborn and stuck
uh on the belief that and they're not
going to change because it represents
something deeper then it's really a
waste of time to go through like this
data and statistics on gun violence or
abortion rates or immigration rates or
whatever it doesn't matter
and i think religions operate that way
you know that
this is my religion this is what i
believe that's it we'll stop uh i'm not
interested in debating it and you could
go through like atheists do they go
through the all the different arguments
for god and why they don't hold water
and therefore it's more likely there's
not a god than there is a god and so on
but that's irrelevant to somebody that
believes for some other reason you know
this gives my meaning my life meaning or
purpose it's what my family is all about
it's all my friends and my social
network are all of this religion i see
everybody every week and and we all go
through the rituals together and it
gives my life meaning and good good
music and the social camaraderie um so
the arguments that you might make
like i will in just a moment uh are
really irrelevant to the believer so
now on that subject of man creating god
so here i take the approach of an
anthropologist or a social psychologist
of religion which of which there are
many who study this that
um again going through where we started
with you know the predictors of people's
religiosity but it also depends uh if
you
take it up one more scale uh where you
happen to have been born in the world
and what century you were born in or
what millennium uh you know if we were
born you and i or anybody in the world
anybody born more than
say 2500 years ago at the time of the
ancient greeks there were no christians
you wouldn't be a christian because
christ wasn't born yet jesus wasn't born
yet there were no christians and uh or
mormons or scientologists or anything
else so very much you know religion very
much the
the god you happen to believe in
is very much determined by where on
earth you happen to have been born by
chance
and what century or millennium you
happen to be born to me
that in conjunction with the fact that
no religion has any particular purchase
on truth that is
uh reliable uh knowledge that that i
have arrived at through
empiricism and reason
and these are the six reasons i i
believe x whatever it is
and there's some way to test it uh
religion doesn't have anything like that
i mean religious believers give their
arguments this is why i believe but it
isn't really why they believe they
believe for these other emotional
psychological reasons and
and again in some cases that's okay like
politically you know there's there's no
one right truth there but um but the
problem arises when religions
claim that they have absolute truth
so in your case you know in iran you
know so you have
you have religious conflicts there with
no way to resolve the problem or if you
want to just turn to the israeli arab
israeli problem you know basically you
got two two guys with they both have a
deed to the same piece of land
and there's no escrow company to go to
to resolve who actually owns it right
because the escrow company is god and
each of them says i have a direct line
to god he told me this is mine and each
of them says that and the anthropologist
from mars goes well which one of you is
right and they just go well i'm right
and the other guy goes i'm right and
there's no way to resolve it there's no
experiment we're going to run to go oh
you're the right one the other one's the
wrong one so you get the land
historically these things are always
settled you know violently through
through war conflict and but we can't do
that anymore because of nuclear weapons
so
uh so we're probably going to be stuck
with this israeli arab problem short of
a two-state solution which is the only
way i
i can see could ever be resolved you
know asking somebody you know could we
pay you
for this particular piece of land you
know it it it's almost like asking
somebody how much they would charge for
sex or for dinner you know if you have
friends to have you over for dinner what
can i pay you you know it's just that's
a sacred value you don't put money on it
and uh so you know there's a whole suite
of
of beliefs like this like organ
donations you know why not sell your
organs well people are very
uncomfortable with this idea and same
thing with prostitution most people are
not comfortable you know
and you know sex workers
that charge for their services
you know that used to be called
prostitution which has a negative
valence to it because
again people have certain sacred valley
values that they'll never give up that
you can't put a price on
and uh and there we that you know that
explains much of the world's conflict i
think
so man created god
not the other way around god that's what
that's what it looks like to me i mean
you know if you kind of lay it out the
different claims made by the different
religions that are in conflict with one
another uh and the and the fact that you
know flood myths are common amongst
religions that you know were born and
raised
that is the religion on a body of water
that floods right or resurrection myths
you know christians claim our ours is
unique you know because we have the
resurrection no that's not true there's
lots of religions with resurrected gods
and the theme of resurrection comes up a
lot
uh either literally or metaphorically
and you know almost all born of a virgin
you know that this is also not unique to
christianity there's lots and lots of
examples of
of deities that are born in a virgins
and you know god's having sex with
humans in the in the ancient uh
greek and roman world around the time
christianity came came online that was
very calm god gods routinely came down
from the heavens had sex with mostly
women
and uh you know then the result were the
virgin births right you know this was
not unusual at the time
and men could become gods or partial
gods and gods could become humans or
partial humans you know so this whole
business that uh that critics of
christianity have about how can you
believe that jesus was
with was both god and the son of god how
can that be
you know there's a problem of identity
you can't be both at the same time well
in the roman times when christianity was
born that was quite common gods could
routinely uh have sex and and become a
human for a while and then return to
becoming just gods and go back to being
human or partial human and that that was
actually a common belief so to me
all elements of all the religions
uh are obviously socially constructed
you know people made them so if you like
the sort of short clip from an interview
i did click over here to watch the
entire interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]